94 victory for brooklyn
that's improved to 15 and 12 showing
some love
to their former teammate karis levert
and everybody just checking on him
levert of course had
surgery to remove a small mass on his
kidney
and the indicator is that everything is
a-okay now it's just a matter of
him getting back to a point where he can
return to the nba he has been shooting
and moving around a little bit
and a good sign that he's just on this
trip absolutely
great to see him great to see him
smiling you know how much love you have
for karis and
sometimes it's funny how things happen
and for a reason and may not have had a
physical and found that
in the timely manner that they did if
not for the trade so for karis of course
we just wish him all the best for his
health for him as a human being
and can't wait to see when he is finally
back on the court
it's four straight losses now for the
pacers
but for the nets one that they needed
with a five-game western swing coming up
the nets improved to 15
and 12 on the season behind 35 points
from
kyrie irving inclu